okay sure yes
thank you fabiola um welcome everybody
um to what will be our final meeting of
this
um municipal year um although we've
actually only had two meetings as a
committee and
do we have any apologies fabiola
uh no apologies received chair okay
um and do we have any declarations of
interest at all
and i'm not aware of any um questions
from members of the public non-received
chair
and we've received the minutes from the
previous meeting
um which was held on the 4th of february
are there any amendments or comments on
the minutes
just a couple of housekeeping um before
we start on the
main agenda um could i ask that if
you're not
speaking you do mute your microphone um
and if you'd like to ask a question or
comment on anything
could you please put that in the chat um
i can't always see everybody
if you're waving at me um but i can keep
checking the chat if that's okay with
everybody
um so if we can move on to
agenda item five which is school places
um can i apologize in advance on behalf
of the officers
um these um reports were slightly late
going out
um because um of pressures on the
service
last week and and i do realize that one
of the
um reports wasn't actually
sent out until friday but um
i i was asked and i did um confirm that
under the circumstances
that that was quite okay so i do hope
the um committee appreciate that
um so i'm going to move on to um school
places i believe we have
um richard rowe corporate director of
place
um karen samples um
who is um director of education
standards
quality and performance and sarah
butter's head of early years
school places and access so um we have
had the report but if you
wouldn't mind one of you just giving us
a brief overview
and then i can give the members of the
committee an opportunity to ask
questions
thank you thank you councillor west and
i'll i'll just
start off very very briefly um obviously
further to the last scrutiny meeting
that we have there was a request to
provide further clarity and information
um on the processes behind school place
planning so
this is what we've endeavored to do this
time it it seeks to hopefully support
you with further data
inform you on the relevant school
planning areas
which i think we didn't have last time
with some details on the impact on the
existing schools
and then obviously any expansion plans
to meet that need and demand
but i'm going to hand over to sarah
butters who is the head of service for
early years school places in access who
can
lead us through some of the the
highlights of the report thank you
thanks karen um so just
as we look at the report um it
reiterates our key strategic priorities
which i think are really important to
keep in mind
around expanding the existing provision
to protect the financial viability of
our schools
removing mixed stage classes and
amalgamation where that's possible
um and then i think it's important to
mention again
that we've been highlighted as an
example local authority for efficient
use of our basic need funding
and also that we've got very strong
forecast accuracy with regards to
projecting the future demand
for school places so that stands us in a
strong position
for making accurate projections for what
we think the future demand will be
um on the dfe scorecards which were
included in the report to the previous
scrutiny committee in february
and there was an estimated number of
additional places
and the dfe had calculated that trafford
needed by 21-22
so the next school year and i wanted to
just clear up a few points around that
so a really important point is that the
dfe calculation
deploys a different methodology to
what we use when we look at our local
sufficiency assessments
so the dfe calculation they assume that
local authorities will provide places
for all pupils who wish to access one
in their area so we know in trafford
we've got high performing popular
schools we're an attractive option
for pupils coming in from out of borough
so that means we know there are always
going to be a lot of pupils that want to
access a place in trafford that don't
live here
so dfe build that into their calculation
of how many places we need to create
that then differs from the local
sufficiency assessment
and this is really what i refer to when
we're talking about
making sure that the local authority
meets its duty to ensure sufficient
places
when we think about that duty it's about
sufficient places for all pupils that
are resident in our area
so given we are a net importer of school
places we attract a lot of pupils from
out of borough
there is a difference there in what dfe
say we need
and what we actually need to make sure
we continue to meet our statutory duty
um in the last meeting um there was some
questions asked
around out of borough pupils and the
proportions of out of borough pupils
access places in trafford schools so we
have provided um two annexes to the
report this time round
and it shows you a breakdown of the
proportion of outer borough pupils
in each of our primary schools in year
seven and then in each
sorry in year reception and then in each
of our secondary schools
in year seven and it highlights the
three year average for that
just to pick out some of those key
figures we know that in the primary
sector we've got four percent of our
borough pupils
accessing trafford provision this does
increase where
we have like in our border area schools
so where we have the manchester border
in
in sale east that's up to eight percent
and in stratford
um it's six percent but four percent
overall for the primary sector
then there's a really big jump when we
look at year seven and the secondary
pupils
so that on the three-year average figure
shows we've got 16 percent of out of
borough pupils
that um are in our traffic secondary
schools
we know a significant contributory
factor for this is the selective
education system so we've got
when we look just at the grammar schools
it's 29 of our
year seven pupils are not resident in
trafford so hopefully that information
that's been provided will answer some of
the questions
around that particular issue
another question that was asked was
around how we were going to meet
the the number of places that the dfe
said that we needed for
21.22 so i just wanted to provide a
little bit of information about that
so for the secondary sector the dfe
calculate we need 520 additional places
so when we divide that by the five-year
groups there are in secondary that's 104
places per year group
so i just wanted to give you a little
breakdown that we've
provided 12 of those in sale high
and we will be providing 80 of those at
bth
um and then also we've got some
additional places coming on board in our
grammar schools
most of them are not yet on board some
of them come on board this year and then
in future years
and they will also contribute to that
need for 520 places or 104 in each year
group
and then for the primary sector it was
330 places needed for 2021
and when we break that down per year
group it's 47 places per year group
and how we are meeting that is we have
already delivered 15 places per year
group
at worthington primary school and we are
underway
um with a proposal to deliver 30 places
per year group at the first
although those places in that proposal
won't be available
until 2022 but we will retain an option
to create some additional places there
if needed
for 2021 so hopefully that clears up the
points that
that members were asking last time about
how we were meeting
the need calculated by the dfe
um another um point that i want to make
is
we know we have a complex system in
trafford and we know that a broad range
of factors
and trends in communities influence the
demand for school places
and that that changes over time and due
to this complexity providing a place for
every traffic
resident child is not always easy to
achieve and we're not pretending that it
is
but it's really important to highlight
that trafford continues to meet the
statutory duty
and by providing a place for every child
that needs one in our area
and so we don't have large numbers of
pupils that can't access our school
system that live in our area everybody
um
has a place um obviously we would make
every effort to accommodate preference
when we're allocating places but
because of how popular our schools are
we're never always going to be able to
meet everybody's preference
and i think it's really important that
we bear that in mind
the final important point around our
approach to school place planning is
we really must achieve the right balance
between providing
sufficient places for everybody that
needs one and over provision
and that's really critical because if we
don't get that right then we're not
going
we're going to sort of lose that
stability from within the existing
school system
and if we over provide places we're
going to compound the financial
challenges that some of our schools are
experiencing
also when we provide additional places
we do it generally in multiples of 30
so it's very difficult for us to create
small amounts of additional places to
meet small amounts of demand
so i think we have to understand that
the report goes on to describe the role
of strategic planning
and importantly how planning i've been
working with the development management
team
and education and that we've all been
working together to try and
predict the future demand um on the
education system linked to new housing
developments in trafford
so the draft trafford local plan
includes a section on education and
skills
and the draft policy highlights our
strategic priority to
invest in expanding our existing
provision and also in seeking developer
contributions where there's going to be
a shortfall of school places locally
created by the new housing developments
and then as karen mentioned it then goes
on to provide
some data so
excuse me um so for the data that we've
provided
we have gone about it by school place
planning area
and and then for each place planning
area we've looked at the supply of
schools and the total number of places
that are currently provided
we've looked at the total number of
surplus places currently so that's based
on the current academic year
and then we've calculated that into a
percentage of surplus places in that
area
and that's split between primary and
secondary and also between non-selective
and selective what it then goes on to do
for each of those areas
is there is an analysis and based on
new developments which are in the
strategic housing land availability
assessment
and also allocations from within the
gmsf
and it provides an analysis with an
estimated
pupil yield for both primary and
secondary places
um which is based on the developments
that are in the schla and are in the
gmsf
so it gives us a kind of estimated um
future
demand for school places it looked at it
in kind of units of forms of entry
and it also breaks it down into the next
five years
the next five to ten years and then the
next 10 to 15 years
and we have carried out a desktop
analysis of all of our existing
school estate and highlighted where
there is potential to expand our
existing primary schools
and this is of course subject to
engagement with local schools but for
each of those areas
we've tried to highlight to you for
primary um the total number of forms of
additional provision that we would be
able to provide from
by expanding our existing school stock
um for each of our areas it then goes on
to highlight some of the key points
about each of those areas
and for some of these areas um it would
highlight that
um so for example in the altering area
and we know we've got additional places
that are going to be created from the
selective school expansion fund at our
grammar schools there
and we know that in the temporary wedge
allocation which is within the jmsf
that land has been identified for a
potential new school
a two-form entry school there in the
future if it's needed
but in that particular area we've
retained an option
to expand our existing schools first
prior to embarking on
opening a new school so it kind of tries
to summarize
what the potential solutions are in each
of those areas to meet the projected
demand which is
illustrated in the table
so that that is provided for each of our
school
place planning areas um
i'm not going to go through the data in
all of those areas but i think very much
we can
perhaps have questions about any of the
data that's been provided
once we've finished with this overview
and then finally in the report it
highlights the next steps
this is really the work the key pieces
of work that we expect to take place
um as we move forward with our joint
work between strategic planning and
education
and so that we can continue to better
understand
what the future impact will be on school
places and how we can provide
solutions to this so i think that's
everything from me thank you
thank you members that have
um asked to ask questions so i'm going
to take them in order
counselor carey
thank you councillor weston and thank
you for that
uh overview of the report um
i um sit on planning committee and
i can still see quite a big discrepancy
here between
what's going on committee and what i can
see in this report
um in regards to educational
contributions how they're being spent
what
what we're being asked to do on planning
committee and what i'm seeing in this
report
um is it okay if i just read through
some things that i've put on here and
then
anyone who wants to comment in them can
if that's all right so i've got a few
little
notes there's not that many but is that
okay chair counselor western
that's fine councillor kerry thank you
um so
one of the first points i'm a bit
concerned about is this school expansion
idea because expanding the school is is
really difficult you know
at least two members on this committee
work in schools and
of the councillors and and it's a really
it's a really big job
um not only that the cost of doing it
um and the provision that we've got what
happens when the schools become no
longer expandable and are at
capacity um
sorry just give me a second um
sorry sorry sorry here we go uh my next
point sorry on 4.2
um i think you've discussed it briefly
there is that the pupil yield rate it
says the prime in the secondary sector
averages three additional pupils per
school year per 100 homes
and you may have just touched on this
but i don't understand how that's
calculated
and is it still fit for purpose in
uh 2021 and you spoke before about this
percentage of pupils who come from out
of area
and around the borders i think you said
it was quite high in our selective
system
and i know that lots of schools in the
borough manage their own admissions
but i just wanted to see some clarity
from user how are those children
sorted if they're sorted with a priority
to the local pupils first
or with um outside of area i i don't
know
and i'm seeing in the data areas of the
the planning areas lots of money from
developer contributions but then
each one of them ends with these are not
yet agreed and would be phased alongside
development
but what happens if they're not agreed
and these things have already started to
be built
and recently in partisan we approved 150
homes with no developer contribution
because the developer had already
contributed to the building of the
renewal of the town center which was
really welcome
but then it's it just doesn't match up
for me the way
things are working and you said in our
area a lot i just like some clarity on
what that means please just specifically
do we mean when we're trying to get a
child in our area as in
a primary school people in getting a
place in a trafford primary school or in
their designated
area and i can't still see any sort of
planning for any
new schools or any places where they
could be built particularly in sale
and with the planning problems that come
with wanting to
expand a school as well i just find a
little bit difficult to understand
um i'd finally just really quickly like
to ask um
do we feel 100 confident that in
september this year and september next
year
or in the next five years from that the
pupils who
live in this borough now just for
example not the few people who are going
to arrive
are going to be able to get you know a
high percentage of them are going to a
really really high percentage of them
are going to be able to get their local
primary school rather than a primary
school
in our area or secondary school so
that's a bit disjointed
i'm not the best at this um and if
anyone would like to try and answer any
of those or just write some comments
that'd be great
thank you um councillor weston as well
thank you who's going to respond to that
um i think i i i can start so there was
there was quite a lot of points there
councillor kerry which i've tried to
make a note of
um i think your first point was around
expansion
and that being a big job and then what
happens when all of our schools are
expanded to capacity
and i think what our desktop analysis
has highlighted is we do have a lot of
schools
where we do we are likely to have
potential to expand
there are some of our schools in
trafford that a single form of entry
which we know is no longer financially
viable as an operational model
so we would definitely want to expand
those even if it is a big job
or you know there might be complications
and
i think it's fair to say that with
regards to school expansions we've
probably done a lot of the ones which at
the easier jobs because they will have
been prioritized
but that doesn't mean that we don't have
schools that we very much can approach
to expand now and often that will be to
the benefit of the school and i think
that's really important
for us to be considering here so it's
not you know we have a two-year time
really for
for going from deciding to expand the
school to actually providing the places
so it is a big job and it does take two
years but equally when we create new
housing developments the people don't
come straight away
you know all have children straight away
you know so there is those timing issues
to consider and i guess when all of our
schools have been expanded that can be
then that is the point at which we would
move to a model where we would only
consider
um creating new schools and actually all
those developer contributions at that
point will be
pulled towards creating additional
provision
and it is important as well to just
think that we know we've got a declining
birth rate at the moment so
thinking about your last point and um
local
people existing in this borough and
whether they'll be able to access
schools
um we we have got a decline in birth
rate
it's we still need to do a bit more work
i think to see exactly what the impact
of that will be in trafford but we are
expecting to be less pupils
um of school age over the next sort of
so many years
um thinking about the pupil yield i
think you asked how it was calculated
and if it's fit for purpose
so we have an average people yield and
we have had it in use for some time
but we do have work plan to um to work
on that and to look at how we can
um look at different types of properties
especially properties that have been
developed recently in the last five
years
rather than looking at all properties
there are ever
we want to really focus on new
development so we can understand
the yield that those developments
produce and especially whether there's
variation in yield between the different
areas
and indeed as far down as school sort of
catchment area level
so that is planned for the summer term
and i think a lot of the analysis that
you see in that report is caveated by
that because
in some of our areas if you think about
stratford for example where those new
developments we've got a lot of
apartments
um if the if the yield for apartments
turns out to be less
or there are more one-bed apartments on
those developments than we're estimating
those kind of factors
that's going to have a really
significant impact possibly by up to one
or two forms of entry
on how much additional demand we do
actually need so i think it's a really
good point you made and that work is
scheduled for the summer term
and then the analysis will be updated to
reflect those updated yields
um when we talked about you mentioned
something about out of borough children
and how children are sorted and you're
right obviously we have the
local authority maintained schools we
have our own over subscription criteria
and we do look to protect traffic
resident children within that
you write though as well that there are
other schools that are their own
admission authority and so we don't have
that level of control
what you will see is in some of the
faith schools for example they often
attract from
over the border because they look at
parish boundaries and things like that
rather than catchment areas
and but i think as far as we can as an
admission authority for those schools
that we're responsible for we do protect
that
um you mentioned also in our area and
what that means
and i think i when i talk about in our
area
there's two parts really so when i'm
talking about our statutory duty that is
about
children that live in trafford so
trafford is our area but when we're
talking about children especially
accessing primary school places we're
talking about children accessing a place
within their local area
and so very much that's around much more
local than at trafford level yeah so i
think that's important to
to make you raised a question about
developer contributions and then not
being agreed
the only point i want to make about that
is many of those have only been
requested maybe since september 2020
so a lot of them are very very recent so
they're not really at the point
at which we would expect them to be
agreed but it might be that some of
my colleagues may be richard or um
might be able to provide a bit more
information about that
i think i addressed all of your points
there counselor kerry
oh thanks so much i really appreciate it
too thank you
did any other officers wish to comment
at all
council weston it's it's richard if i
could just comment if that would be okay
um thank you and thank you for the
invite
this is the first time i've been to
children's school to meet in 10 years at
the council so
it's a pleasure uh to be here um
as well as couple of things one just to
emphasize the point that
sarah made in the efforts that we have
undertaken at officer level of the last
couple of years to really make sure that
we're aligning the work that's being
done
through karen and sarah and her team
around school first planning
with the development management team and
the strategic planning
team so we really think about education
education
and provision as part of developing our
proposals because we really understand
the importance
of that to um to residents to
communities and to
and to members and
since april 2019 we have secured just
over two million pounds
in um section 106 contributions
for uh for education um plus
uh on top of that is the potential
provision for a new school within the
lumina village care site application
and if it's not a school on there then
there's potential of up to
1.8 million pounds of education
contribution um
as well and that's a useful case in
point where we're
undergoing an exercise now working with
local schools and education colleagues
to assess whether
is the right approach expansion and
maintaining existing schools
or is it a new school recognizing that
that's an area of
significant development the timing of
when those contributions come in
is dependent on when the development
starts so the contribution is
secured and agreed as part of the
planning commission but then is
generally will be paid at airport in the
development
process and depending on the scale of
development may well come through in
person
and we will be working with education
colleagues then to look at our
school first planning where the
opportunities for expansion are as
sarah said and then also on the bigger
developments so thinking about the
places for everyone
plan and the strategic developments of
current and simply wedge
but also some of the existing
developments such as traffic waters
we'll be looking at including new
schools as part of those
as part of those developments but again
ensuring that we do that in the way
that works with the existing existing
score
and there is always a challenge on
timing as to exactly what point
that score provision um comes online
what you don't want to do is open it too
early because that's financially very
different for the school because you're
opening it when
the pupil yield is relatively is
relatively no low and the numbers are
small
but neither do you want to be too late
because then you're putting pressure on
an additional additional score so that's
that is something that we're really
working through to understand the best
timing
for this to happen thank you thanks
richard um
councillor procter you had a question
yeah yeah i tried doing all today and it
didn't work
um i have i did have one question i now
have
a request as well it's already seven
o'clock
we've got a lot on the agenda can we
stick to one question each
so that everybody then has chance to ask
any questions
and then if there's time have a
supplementary question
after others have spoken please and then
my
question is why do we have
so many out of borough children in our
schools if we need more places for
traffic children
i understand that the bulk of the
grammar schools
control what they do but the other
schools
why that trafford control why are we
allowing them
to take out a bull replacement when we
need places for
our own children first thank you
i think i could perhaps come in with
that one um when we think about our
secondary schools
we actually only have one secondary
school which is local authority
controlled and actually
all of the rest of those secondary
schools have their own admissions
policies and over subscription criteria
so
i think that's an important point to
make um
when we're thinking about primary
schools really four percent's quite low
in terms of those outer borough children
one of the ways it was described once to
me was that actually often those out of
borough children can keep the seats warm
for trafford children for when they're
needed so it helps schools with their
financial
viability because we can attract places
from out of borough pupils
for when there is not a demand from
within trafford but actually
when we do create additional demand or
more people moving to that catchment
area within trafford
that can then push out those
non-trafford residents meaning our own
children can take up those spaces
but the school has not been impacted
along the way by having empty seats
without the finances to go with it
thank you sarah um
thank you thank you chair um yeah i i
actually think it's an
excellent report it's very detailed very
comprehensive um
you know for the plans for the school
places
um and it's encouraging to know that
we continue to provide everyone a place
in our
schools and i think we've consistently
done that and
uh and i think the other thing that
um you know sort of shouts out to me
is that this is a rolling plan
really isn't it because it's so dynamic
uh the circumstances are so dynamic in
terms of
uh building new houses and um
you know the number of children birth
rates
and all of those kind of issues
um and and it is very complex
what the question that i had really
was to do about the um
through the planning process the housing
developers
on large sites building a lot of houses
contributing to
school places um but what it does say
in in in the report um
was that a notable exception to this
are the conversions of office buildings
uh to residential um
accommodation um that the government
has decided to allow permitted
development for those
kinds of developments and therefore
the authority cannot condition
new um converted accommodations to
contribute towards
school places this seems to be
you know an anomaly that
um that goes against
what we're trying to do in terms of
uh making some of the developers
contribute to
those places that we need and i think
it's something that
you know the council may wish to
um sort of make representations to the
government about this because
uh you know if there are a lot of
families that uh take up these
accommodations
and we get no sort of uh contribution
for the school places um you know it
could
could could throw the system out so
um it's just a thought really
i don't know whether richard rose got
anything to say in terms of the planning
i know that permitted planning is what
it is permitted
planning and uh but it it's something
that i would be concerned about
so thank you chair would you like me to
respond to that um
um uh i think your
summary at the end there uh counselor
acting on um it is what it is
is uh is correct um
permitted development rights are uh
permitted it's nationally prescribed
uh it's not something that the council
out control
um over but it does give us um
a challenge when we're looking at things
like education contributions and other
contributions and
i think as sarah said in a
note traditionally people yield from
apartments has been a lot lower from
houses they've not been seen as family
accommodation
but we know that that's something that
is changing and will probably
continue to change so it's something
that we will need
and we will need to keep an eye on
and i know overall when we can um
look at developers not necessarily going
through permitted development rights if
they are making
changes to significant changes as well
on top of the conversion from office to
residential then it may be that they do
need a planning
permission to do that so where there is
the opportunity to look for
contributions then we will do
but other than that we are we are
required to
fall in line with uh national
legislation and we've seen it
a number of schemes of office conversion
to residential in particular
in uh crippled world and the area around
seymour grove
but also in and around the centre of
altringham
as well
two more questions i have a question
from um
karina carter who is our lead member for
education and
i also have um council london wishes to
ask a question
um could i ask that we um
make this rather brief i'm cognizant of
the time um
so if i could just limit you to one
question if that's all right
um councillor carter do you
yeah i'll be really quick denise it's
just um a question
a question for clarification really i've
seen some information in the public
domain
saying that we do not have enough places
for children
particularly in the sale area and it's
my understanding that we do have enough
places
and um particularly with the expansion
of the furs
coming on on stream for september so i
just
would like one of the officers to
clarify that we do have enough places
for children
uh yeah i can probably do that counselor
carter and so
we do we we're obviously working now on
the primary allocations for september
2021 um
and yes we do have enough places for for
all the children that want one that
currently live in our area
and with the furs the proposal to expand
the furs
um is to bring the places online in 2022
but we do have um we have maintained an
option to be able to create additional
reception places in september 2021
should the need arise but at the moment
it looks like we won't need
you thank you for the them i understand
that um
perhaps if you needed more information
we could request that
um in writing at a later day if that's
all right for you
okay thank you um thank you to
all our officers um for their um
very detailed and informative responses
and
i'm going to move on now to um
item six and um
oops we have with us um pamela wharton
who is our director of
early help and children's social care
and anna lomas who is the
strategic lead for children in care and
again could i ask we have had the
reports
um could we have a brief overview
and to give members an opportunity to
ask questions
thank you councillor weston could i just
ask if you're okay if i leave the
meeting now it's here for the school
place i don't want to go without your
your nod
that's absolutely fine richard thank you
for coming and i hope we've not
put you off attending future meetings no
no very i'm
very happy to come and future that's
great
thank you thank you and and i'm also
going to be
to be leaving if that's okay because i
was just here for that for that i did
thank you okay thank you bye
um good evening thank you chair for that
i i will just start and give um an
introduction to this and then and anna
will
pull out some salient points as you've
said members if i've had the
paper before and we do want to leave
time for questions
um so we we were asked um
at the previous scrutiny committee to to
table a paper
particularly looking at foster care and
how that had been
impacted with the pandemic and and i
think what i would say is
is like any family our fostering
families have
have been impacted by the pandemic they
face the same challenges that all
families face but there is an added
layer of complexity when you're then
looking after other people's children
um to factor in to to family life
so i know we we've had some of our
foster carers
that have um have needed to isolate from
seeing their own children and
grandchildren
so that they can continue looking after
our children
and facilitate their family time with
their birth families
so there have been huge sacrifices
made um from some of our fostering
families and we are
incredibly grateful for that they do an
absolutely
um fantastic job at looking after our
children
and just wanted to just kind of offer a
thank you to our fostering families for
that we know that this has been
a difficult time we have detailed in the
report
a breakdown of the number of fostering
families that we have in trafford which
hopefully will be useful
and given some explanation of the
different types of fostering households
that we have
so we have connected carers who are
approved as foster carers to look after
children who they are related to or know
so it's usually grandparents or aunties
or uncles
but can be cousins or friends of the
family who
in difficult circumstances in birth
families have stepped in
to take responsibility for for children
and who've become looked after and so we
have
63 of those connected carers but we have
more children
placed with those carers so we we
we have um a number of um
mainstream fostering households 101 but
then they have they have less children
placed
and some of that is related to brother
and sister groups
which we we come on to highlight in the
report that is a is a challenge
for us to in internal capacity to place
brother and sister groups of two three
and four together that
uh that is more challenging for us and
that's been impacted through corvid
so i'll pass on to anna just to go
through some of the things that we've
been doing in the fostering service to
to try and support our foster carers
haven't always got it right but you know
always open to listening to feedback
from
um from people to look at how we can
adjust
and adapt our service in this time
so i'll hand over to to anna thank you
good evening um so thank you pamela
that's really a really useful overview i
think
um what i would say uh echoing what
pamela has said
um is that um it has been a particularly
challenging
um time and an unprecedented only
only kind of um you know
hardly hardly kind of uh communicates
the impact of the
um on our fostering families i think
it's absolutely right to point out the
personal sacrifices that our foster
carers have made and each and every one
of them have done that in in different
ways
and what we've been really keen to do
from the beginning of the
um pandemic is make sure that we support
our fostering
families to continue fostering and
caring for children
as much as possible in the way that
other families do
so that we recognize that they um first
and foremost they are families they
often have their own birth children
there themselves
in the household and we need to make
sure that we wrap around them and
support them
in the way that we would other families
as well and
we have done that so our kind of key
strategies around that
is about really making sure that we get
our communication
right so making sure that we're sharing
information but also making sure we've
got opportunities to really listen to
our foster carers
and building the strengths of what we're
calling our fostering community
so that we can really build the strength
of how our foster carers support each
other
as well through peer support and als
also through
through things like our newsletter and
through social media and through
um support groups and training and we've
particularly kind of modeled
our um our training program this year
in terms of looking at um ways in which
we can support foster carers to build
their emotional
resilience and also to build their skill
base in terms of therapeutic
um responses to our children we know
that the
the covid and the coverage pandemic has
brought
huge um challenges in terms of emotional
health
and well-being for not just children but
also
adults as well and so that um that
focus on on really strengthening and
and building the resilience and
therapeutic approach
um has been really key to be being able
to support people through that process
but we've also um thought about the
practical and emotional
and support that we can provide and been
really keen to make sure that we link
foster carers up with each other
and that we think of ways of being of
helping in a practical way as well
and we have um spent
some time really being very
using our kind of our risk assessments
to really focus
our energies on um on who needs our
support the most
so we know that there are some of our
foster carers um
who are have um complexities in terms of
their own health
and we also know that a significant
number of our
our fostering households um have
at least one often two members of the
household
who are over 60 um and um
as as a result have been had the added
kind of complexities and
um real health risks but also
um the kind of very real fears that of
of um
many of those carers have experienced so
we've been really keen to make sure that
we really focus and understand
those carers that uh need the most um
support and we've used a kind of a risk
assessment model
to identify um carers who are um
you know rated as red and so carers that
have the highest risk associated with
their
their profiles and their their current
situations
those are amber um and those that are
green um
so that we can really uh make sure that
we're focusing support in the right way
that um that rag rating has been really
useful not just for the fostering team
but to work across teams
so we've been able to share that with
our virtual school with our social work
teams
so that we can really all understand the
foster carers that need our support
the most and make sure that we're
focusing um and
making getting our support offer right
for them
um training has overview um
could i just um stop you there thank you
we have had the reports
um i just wondered if um any counsellors
or members of the committee would would
like to ask a question i know
um councillor dylan would like to ask a
question sorry to interrupt you but
okay conscious of time thank you
thank you chair i'd just like to ask if
when we do these sort of things again if
we could have some actual foster carers
or
parents of adoptive children or whatever
i just think it would give us a more
rounded
set of information that's all i wanted
to say thank you yeah
yeah that's that that would be i agree
that would be um
that would be really useful and give
that other other kind of perspective as
well
i think that would be a really good idea
um counselor proctor you have a question
thank you chair i've actually got five
but i'm asking one
i'm going to provide the rest as written
questions
unless we've got time
what i'm concerned about is the
recruitment
i've gone through the report in
great detail because looked after
children is something
very important to me as a retired foster
carer
for trafford
and we we we're losing more foster
carers than we're gaining
do exit interviews happen with the
foster carers
who leave and if so
what happens to that information because
if it's a tick box exercise it's a waste
of time
and if they're not being done we've got
no information about why
foster carers are choosing to leave and
from
experience of some of my friends who are
foster carers
when they've hit difficulties with their
particularly looked after child the
weekend
duty team have been worse than useless
in meeting their support needs and that
concerns me
if that happens on a regular basis and
could contribute to foster carers
choosing to stop fostering thank you
okay um shall i reply to that now
yeah um exit interviews so that the
process of
um uh kind of ending a foster carer's um
approval could come about in in
different ways so i have outlined those
um those kind of circumstances broadly
in the report in terms of those carers
that have left
um left our kind of fostering uh
community this year i what i would say
is that we do as well as exit interviews
we do use exit interviews but we also
make sure that if um if foster carers
are um are leaving our service because
um there is a a review that's been
undertaken
that they also have an opportunity to
represent their views
um and to and to provide their views for
the fostering panel so that that's
included in the process and so that
is um it is um you know a requirement in
terms of
our um our fostering panel would expect
that report to be there obviously some
foster carers um choose not to provide a
report but they they
um our fostering panel will always ask
um
and and um kind of seek that that um
that direct report from the foster carer
um exit interviews are used and i would
say um
what we understand is very varied
reasons
for why people um move on from and from
fostering there are some there is a
there is an example of um for example
one foster carer that i'm aware of that
has moved to foster for another local
authority
and that's um the reason for that was to
do
with the um profile of children that we
were able to place
um uh that we were that we were
um receiving referrals for which didn't
um which didn't match the the profile of
children that she
um wanted to care for um so
we understand very much that it's not
just about making sure we recruit foster
carers but also we recruit
the foster carers for the kinds of
children that we need
need to care for it's really important
that we get that match right and it's
not just about numbers
and because if it's about numbers for
example if we just
you know it's relatively easy for us to
recruit foster carers for babies for
example
um when actually the you know one of our
most significant areas um in terms of
the kind of profile of children that we
need placements for
is sibling groups and older children
so we could recruit 10 foster carers for
babies and actually not impact on our um
on our fostering sufficiency in the way
that we need to
and those foster carers would likely end
up
sitting with vacancies and becoming
quite frustrated that they you know they
have that vacancy
so it's really important that we get the
match right between
the kind of carer that we're looking for
and the
and the and the kind of children and the
age profile
of children that we are um knee
placements for
um we have had some um some carers that
have
um as i've said in the report we have um
quite a significant number of carers who
are over the age of 60 and 70
um and we have had some carers two two
carer households that have decided to
retire after many years of fostering
um who were in their late 70s and and
one in their 80s
uh and i think it's you know it's a it's
a it's fantastic they were able to
foster for that long and actually got to
got to a point where actually they
decided you know they want to retire so
there are very varied reasons
but some of them are um you know some of
them are related to
us not getting it right in terms of the
profile of carers that we
recruit and the profile of children that
we um
that we need placements for um
in terms of you mentioned about edt
um and what i would say is that um
we work closely with our edt
um service what we ensure is that we
have
a um a kind of close feedback with
foster carers if they're
if they are experiencing difficulties
with um contacting edt and that we feed
that back into
um for learning for our edt team and
what we've been trying very much to do
is is build a that sense of a fostering
community so that
foster carers are not um
that don't so the foster carer's only
option isn't to phone edt
but actually is to in some experience in
some situations to phone another
experienced foster carer
who they're linked up with as a mentor
and so we have a mentoring scheme that
enables foster carers to be
linked with each other um as as a new
carer
um you would be linked with an
experienced mentor
and that's a scheme that we're we're
working hard to develop because we know
that what foster carers say is that that
support is absolutely invaluable in
terms of understand somebody who
understands their
their kind of point of view from from
from kind of standing in their shoes and
from
having had similar experiences
themselves so
it the redt service can be stretched at
times
but but it's by no means the only um
kind of source of support that is
available for foster carers
we do work hard to make sure that the
carers feel supported
and in other ways as well bye
sorry you i can't hear you
yes unmuted thank you
i'd also like to apologize because i
think what i said was rather harsh
um it comes from the experience of one
particular family
who struggled massively over a weekend
and the support they needed
just wasn't provided um
i'm glad to hear about um
mentoring happening because that was
happening when i was a foster carer and
it kind of
dissipated so i'm really glad that's
happening again because
that is crucial especially for brand new
foster carers thank you
yeah are you happy to put your other
questions
in writing um yes and um if
anna you're happy to supply the answers
in writing
thank you and apologies for interrupting
halfway through your that's fine
um thank you um
who is our exact member for um
children's services did you want to just
make a comment there
really really briefly it was only just
to add that um
we are going through um a a listening
um kind of exercise really a number of
listening exercises to understand
um more about how um
how we can better and further support
our foster carers
um and completely modernize the service
really to
make sure that it we do wrap around um
support around all our foster carers um
and jill and i have met with um foster
carers
recently and uh former foster carers as
well
um and that there's a
and i'm not sure if it's in the report
actually i think it might be but if it
isn't um just to let members know that
that there is a
an exercise we've commissioned some um
somebody external from
from the authority um to um
to listen to foster carers as well
because i think it is really incredibly
important that
um we do recruit foster carers and that
we retain the foster carers that we've
got and we can only do that by making
sure that
um you know that the foster carers are
um
as well supported as as they can be
really so it was just to have that
thanks chair
thank you cath um i
can't see any more um
i've got a note from um pamela wharton
and say that the work is being
undertaken regionally through
uh greater manchester combined authority
so
um that's helpful to know um
thank you um
if there are no more questions i can't
see any um
indication in chat that there are any
more questions
so thank you for the report and
thank you to um anna um
for your very detailed responses um
if everybody's happy um could i move on
to
um the report of the task and finish
group on
send and school exclusion um
this was a piece of work which followed
on um
from our um task and finished group in
the previous
um municipal year which looked at
ehcps um it's been
um challenging as you can imagine with
covid and we haven't actually been able
to meet face-to-face
with as many um representatives as we've
wished um
i'm not going to read through report
members have had this
um and it was issued um in a timely
fashion
just going to highlight uh very briefly
um
some of our recommendations before um
submitting um this report to the
committee for their approval for it to
go to the exec
and so um the main points are
that um trafford schools and colleges
supports
all employees working directly
with um students undergo training
and to remote to promote the traffic
inclusion
charter to procure a new data system
which would allow systematic and
periodic monitoring of all sense
students
to consider increased funding for
independent seniors
support and advice advisory services
um to facilitate opportunities for
trafford schools to capitalize on
existing expertise professionals
of send professionals and to encourage
all traffic schools to ensure that
any child at risk of permanent exclusion
has had adequate and appropriate
assessments
to enable parents to report on the
council's website
any concerns about their child and get
advice
and to ensure all ehcps are of good
quality and legally compliant
and to continue the provision of the
step out program
with that um i'd like to present a
report um
with many thanks to um the task and
finnish group
who have persevered with this throughout
the pandemic um
are there any questions from members at
all
no um can't see any
um hands up or anything in the chat
um our members are happy to accept the
report
um and for it to be submitted to the
executive
i can see a lot of oh uh council london
did you have a question
i think my apologies chad no i didn't
did you have a question
i think stephen may have um
i.t issues you just keep freezing
council london
yeah my apologies charity it is a little
bit difficult i think it's my end and
that's why i'm
trying not to speak
okay council hines has asked um could
she make
a brief comment on this um
um if you could if you're able to write
in chat
if you have a question or a comment
thank you
um i'm going to hand over to um
councillor hines
it was only just two um really welcome
the
uh the the report and i can imagine that
it has been really challenging
um in it you know with the restrictions
but actually you can see how much work
um
and commitment and dedication has gone
into this report and it's highlighted
um an incredibly important
issue so um i look forward to that
coming to
the executive um and uh you know so that
we can
um we can work through the
recommendations and
and prepare a report um in response
um but just to say thank you very much
for that and there were some things in
there
um that um that i hadn't been aware of
previously so it was really
helpful to see that thank you
thank you
i'm not aware um of any
urgent business um
um this evening require the exclusion
resolution
um so with that i'd like to
um bring the meeting to a close um
with a thank you to all the officers and
exec members who have
attended tonight thank you to
the committee members for their
contributions and input
over the last year um and a very special
thanks to fabiola for all her help and
support
over the last two years um with this
committee
um and with that um
we don't know what this committee is
going to look like i would love to be
able to meet you all
um in the flesh as it were um
at our next meeting whenever that may be
but
in the meantime i will bid you all good
night um
safe journey to wherever you are going
presumably the next room
um and thank you again and stay safe
everybody
thank you everyone good morning good
night